I cannot really describe to you the emotions of the kids.
It's something as if they have got a new friend that can be only his friend.
This time of heavy bombardments, there's nothing we can do.
At least we can bring some joy to these kids.
One of my daughters, Jasmine, at that time told me, "Daddy, kids need to play with toys."
And I told her toys are expensive.
I cannot buy toys for all the hundreds of kids.
She said, "I have so many toys, I don't need to play."
"Why don't you take them?"
I walked for about hours now, for about six, seven hours, with all these toys with me.
I have tried hard to dodge a bullet.
If I make it, a lot of kids will be happy.
Kids keep on coming to me and saying, "You see all these toys I have?"
"These are all from you."
"I've been collecting them."
"I have a family of toys now."
It's just beautiful.